[Music]
in fast food beatdown news submitted by
Brenda from NYC sup New York City Brenda
you have pizza
Brenda tab Leone a Burger King customer
witnesses employees fighting through the
drive-through window tell me did you
have a video oh right so the story
behind this video is a mother was trying
to get ice cream for her son sure place
in North Carolina so when she pulled up
in the drive-thru that's when she saw it
oh man the girl in the Burger King oh my
god don't have dreads homie you can get
it grabbed in a fight what's going on
two dudes I think it's two dudes who is
a lady trying to break it up no oh she
did him with the truth
now see is it oh my god
simply hamburger whopper is that what
you recorded the [ __ ] [ __ ] what for
well it's a good thing she's recording
it yeah I think people just get
aggression chain reaction hahaha and
then they just want to fight collateral
damage she said I could see my ice cream
from here she was still talking about
the ice cream she's like your name she's
like this it reminds me of the dog park
you guys ever go to the dog park and
then when the dog two dogs start getting
a little aggressive and in a bunch of
other dogs around them oh yeah getting
like that energy and then every time I
watch it or up like that it's like
contagious everyone the ones that are
trying to stop it also get it and then
they started like beating up people
[ __ ] you last people to fight were the
first people to be like you know yeah
try to stop it she was mad at her for
recording yeah she was that you
recording this [ __ ] [ __ ] what fo you
know why he's entertaining come on now
girl oh why did she say [ __ ] I don't
know did a whole team get fired maybe
because she wanted to have the viral
video so she got jealous [ __ ] I already
got it
I know it's already uploaded on
worldstar job it's live what was the
reason why they were fighting so they're
saying that they were the two men were
fighting because one employee had been
disrespectful towards a female customer
so he was protecting the female customer
like that if I was working at a
fast-food restaurant and somebody
disrespected a customer I could give a
[ __ ] Les Deux yeah you could spit in the
lady's face and I will just do this I'd
be left it happened I feel like make up
excuses to fight yeah this sure like
babe and then they want to be the hero
they already know they're gonna find any
was for justice
it's a peacekeeper yes Burger King or
spokesperson Burger King did do the
whole like this does not demonstrate of
course we already know that even if you
say that dumbass the King disapproves
the franchise owner terminated the team
members who were involved and the girl
that yelled yeah he's a go yeah she was
involved and then the owner will have
all employees complete supplementary
guests experience training and in case
you were wondering that the kid ever get
the ice cream the kid did get the ice
cream because it was very clean next but
early Wow yeah why'd you go to dare
cream in the first place way better yeah
it's like when she went to Dairy Queen
and then I was on her way back she had
to pass Burger King and she could hear
fighting in the parking lot a shooter
like how come in and out does things so
much better because wholesome Christian
company and chick-fil-a chick-fil-a it's
also holds a true subpoena now it has
nicer Christians than the Christian
Church oh for sure
ads that happen I don't know how is that
yeah about your best buy experience Oh
so I thought all best buyers were the
worst [ __ ] in the world right can I go
to the one right here
and then what I guess I have to use any
things real quick and then they always
ask me they're like hey let me know I
help you with anything you need the
first question I asked they'd already
don't know anything why do you even work
in this sex you don't know jack-shit it
happens at every single Best Buy I won't
wait Joe to go buy a backpack before and
then really oh do you have this one in
this colored you're like well did you
check on the shelf and it's like mother
[ __ ] is your job you tell me in the
computer if there's another one go to
the back and check the stock mighta ass
yeah but I went to the one in Santa
Clarita and then I also went to another
one in Pasadena and I think different
Best Buy's have way different service
these fools were going above and beyond
like we have this one person come to our
house to give me like a consultation on
certain things and then this dude was
telling me if if I really want to see
how everything operates go to the
showroom and Pasadena I need is like
also if you want you to come to my house
I'll just show you don't like what the
watch
and then another in-home consultant he
was hitting
what was this for so this one is for a
home networking okay see so you weren't
dealing with the best my employee
oh well he's the best my employee he
actually saw him Best Buy there's
actually three brands underneath just
Magnolia yeah just like the theater top
end people peak squad then there's no no
so gig squad is under Best Buy and then
there's also Pacific sales
I guess American olia is like the cream
of the crop type people but man that
service is insane and then we were going
through to order like washer/dryer like
if you order a whole bundle you get a
discount off the whole of things were
always just buy everything at once and
our order was gonna get delayed because
you know if you have different things
they're all coming at different times
for different stores the other end home
consultant that was a lady she was like
you know what I'm gonna find out which
ones are delaying it and I'll Drive to
those stores physically myself and
assemble all of it I'm like oh if I
could get Best Buy like twelve stars on
Yelp on just these two locations I would
they completely change delivered like by
the end of it everything that's to come
yet but she's still working on it and I
have two direct lines of cell phone so I
didn't have to go through you don't ego
call Best Buy for whatever 0+1 got the
guy huh I have two dudes or a girl in
the dude that I have direct lines with
so that tells me Best Buy is like a
third-world country you go in and you're
dealing with the [ __ ] rice paddy
workers the regular people you're
working with the [ __ ] Ox that's
driving the [ __ ] you know and then when
you get to the top tier yeah
those kind of even you prince level
service awesome I'll tell you this
though still [ __ ] Best Buy
how about that oh not anymore from me I
haven't gone there in a while I just
don't do that kind of [ __ ] Sam I just
wanna know does that mean I have nothing
to buy okay okay I don't own nothing if
you need a washer and dryer or microwave
or some [ __ ] I don't know nothing about
laundry you don't have to buy a fridge
Oh baby years I stopped talking about it
already I know why buy a fridge it sucks
yeah Chris likes her first location
where we met her she's been talking
about that fridge the same fridge you
still use that same one same one good
fridge though think about it well after
that long
yeah it's been my first ugly since
moving on about issue
no so
those 20 since I was 20 you watch your
own fridge 29 now yeah buying your own 3
that he's grown folks I've never bought
a fridge it was from Ikea so it was very
affordable I don't even know they have
fridge I mean even just a building good
but now I came there is no written [ __ ]
no yeah so then that was my first like
my own apartment it was I felt so hard
for you to get rid of don't get rid of
it you know but the reason why we need
it is because it is really small and
like the lighting in it isn't that great
you could change the light bulb you know
so she likes that all her [ __ ] to match
right this girl got some [ __ ] I think
it's wallpaper paper she wrapped her
fridge to change the color of it arrived
good silver but no wholaver you get it
because the handle seems still white oh
my god just buy it you free so then that
recently it's been leaking something
like God dying on me I gotta get on your
fridge but then every time I turn
looking at a fridge it's just you know I
get overwhelmed with the options and the
tune and do you need other appliances
cuz I can hook you up with my potterson
they'll come your house and they'll talk
to you about your needs and they'll
figure it out for your needs
I need this cold that's it you need a
fridge well you know I have been
considering doing like a trade-in thing
with my washer and dryer because they're
practically mean you sound like you're
talking about cars like Carmack's types
do do that though that's bridges that
leaves because I trade it in that's
dough we need to tell them that you
built it yourself good
but yeah my wash under socks like I hate
it every time I do laundry
go away leave a steam it - because the
dryer it comes out all wrinkled your
place came raw like it didn't have a oh
it doesn't have a stove stove a stove
yeah and an oven which is the same thing
a dishwasher and dishwasher that's it I
have to provide my fridge and my washer
and dryer I bet you've been lucky no my
first appointment I go to the laundry
room oh no I still left I left the
washer and dryer at the condo because
it's just too much of a [ __ ] to take it
out he's like whatever that's how we
left ours at this house and it costs to
install - yes I'm like what the [ __ ] cuz
I the movers have to take it out and
everything else when they wear this
thing and the strapping and they carry
that's crazy time cuz it's just one dude
he's like [ __ ] a robot it like
balances and I actually move the fridge
no not by myself I almost said by myself
but no cuz it was light enough for me to
move it around my apartment so my keys
[ __ ] right there yeah the first time I
had a fridge with the ice thing that's
when I knew I made it dude that's true
it does crush I don't got one anymore
I'll get a new fridge from my apartment
but this it comes with the apartment so
I can't get rid of that fridge she's so
[ __ ] small I hate it dude I love our
new fridge our newest it and then I have
this thing with Casey that's really
annoying that so we only have one light
bulb for the fridge right and then
there's like multiple shelves the rest
of the shells could be completely empty
but he needs to put things on the top
shelf that covers the [ __ ] light you
can't see inside the fridge he's six
foot three dude he needs to do in the
higher one that drives me insane he cuts
a grapefruit and puts it on the light
maybe it is this it to piss you off now
well she's being a [ __ ] today he's all
like no perfect loaf of bread that just
sticks ripe and just cut it all up
[Music]
[Music]